let's dive into things well first i want
to know how have you been handling this
new normal priyanka you said you're
going to set
tomorrow the first time you've been on a
flight really since the beginning of
pandemic so
how are you hanging with this new normal
and really
embracing it and are you staying safe um
we've been
very very safe actually because nick is
type one i'm asthmatic
so um you know we've just been like
super careful
about um who we interact with and how we
do it um
but i i don't know i'm i'm so excited
about going back to set
i haven't been at work i mean i've been
doing a lot of
developmental stuff and um producing a
bunch of work
so actually quarantine has been very
very productive for both me
and nick yeah i know samita what about
you dear how have you been handling this
new norm
oh i it is um it's
weird right the new normal is to be like
super protective of yourself and
like really close down and and i really
miss people
and it's a big part of what we do so
that is
a big loss um but i have reached like
new heights of frustration
in pacing my apartment so that that's
that's cool to know that i can have
highs and lows the higher and lower than
i've had than before
and i'm grateful for being safe and
also like getting to connect with people
through these these movies that are
coming out because it's
not traffic i don't miss you know
being stuck in traffic and going for
meetings i'm actually really grateful to
be able to
you know wear sweatpants with like a
formal shirt and you know
do an interview with you
and i got my house shoes on and
everything y'all would never know
yes we are the house you queen i'm
barefoot
but i like that too yeah for sure and
we're also taking away the positive that
we've had some really great content to
watch
and evil eye is gonna be one of those
gems right there i tell you for sure
are you wearing a bracelet yes good it
will protect you darling
if you're not careful bad things could
happen do you guys believe
in the evil eye and just how
superstitious are the two of you
you must i don't know it's like the more
you say you don't like you're testing
fate a little bit i don't know it's like
when you are given
a a charm or like given something from a
family member or
to like keep you safe like you
definitely want to keep it with you
to keep you safe you don't want to like
test it whether that's like uh
um yeah real or not so i i think i
i do i kind of like i like being
superstitious a little bit it's my way
into kind of the horror aspect of things
where you're just like
you kind of like to be thrilled by the
unknown and
um like fate a little bit yeah now i
hear you what about you priyanka are you
superstitious at all
i grew up in india and um i i wouldn't
say it's
called necessarily superstition in
india it's more culturally normal
of um it's it's almost seen as faith
it's almost seen as
belief in something larger than yourself
um
and yes the i mean my upbringing was
surrounded by a you know a normalization
of you know something larger than
yourself so
i would say that i have a subliminal
belief at the back of my head about it
like i don't like jinxing things
if there's something i'm really excited
about is with the project like if and
it's happening i won't even tell anyone
about it till like i put pen to paper
like i'm
i'm superstitious like that but i don't
think i would
like even the evil eye like i i used to
wear
an elab bracelets for a really long time
and um you know whatever you can do to
be
in the right side of things so priyanka
though you got it you got to be honest
with me girlfriend you got to tell me
who's the bigger scaredy cat
you or your boy nick when it comes to
one horror film i'm
nothing moves him he watches him be like
completely stoic
and i'm like inside his you know shirt
by the end of it
like we were watching the boys recently
as well
and loved that show and um i
most of the show i've seen like this
like inside
its arm like because that's i'm just a
scaredy cat um
but what i loved about this movie and i
read it actually as a play what that
madhuri had written initially
and um my exact nina brought it to me
and she was like you know just this play
is super interesting and i was like
it compelled me so much because of
multiple reasons
um you know having two really strong
female
parts i have a very very um tight
relationship with my mother
um and i love that mother-daughter
relationship i my
quest in life as a producer is to influx
hollywood with brown people
because we don't see enough of us and um
to be able to do
an all south asian cast in a movie with
amazon and
glum house who are both like powerhouses
was a dream come true for me
i want to demand leading parts for
people
who look like me i want to have girls
that look like me
samitha even sarita you know be on the
poster of a movie
i want their names to come in first you
know and that's my quest
is to not be a check in the box and to
create content which
represents one-fifth of the world's
population which is
indian everything that i am i learned in
the
industry in india um and to be able to
bring that and
into hollywood i it's my greatest joy
and honor to be able to create
opportunities where i didn't have
everything
can i just say don't move in with him
until you're married
okay ma come on i'm just asking this one
thing
it's like i'm old-fashioned it was an
exciting movie and i feel like so many
things that
even though it's an indian culture and a
family that's being talked about i feel
like so many people can relate in some
elements of the story in particular
pushy mama when it comes to getting
married so i've either of y'all had to
deal with some mamas who were getting a
little pushy and being like okay
it's time to get married ladies let's go
yeah right i have two older sisters
and i um i'm they're like a bit older
six and eight years older than me so i
was like
the teenager was sort of watching behind
the scenes
the like the kind of pressure they were
getting
yeah i mean my mom was the opposite
honestly she was like
you know what follow your career she got
married late
at that time she was like 30 when she
got married 28
29 um and she's been a career woman
so she was like you know whenever you
feel like it's right for you in fact i
used to put that pressure on myself
really i'm 35 i'm never gonna get
married
i'm 36 and every time i went on the
other side of 30
i was like what am i doing my mom was
like stop it do you know who you are
look at the achievements that you
created so i had the other
thing where i i put the pressure
societal pressures
on myself um because i was like oh my
gosh am i
just working too hard that's what i've
been told right like
my use is when i get married and have
kids but
um that's not what my family taught me
and i
am so um so honored by the fact that
they
gave me that kind of freedom and
independence to to
be that what is amazing about this story
is it's
yes it it deeply touches upon
cultural aspects and uh you know what
superstitions could be but it's the
story of
you know a girl like sunita's character
is a normal american girl
she lives in america she's not defined
by
where she comes from who she was which
country she's coming from she has normal
everyday aspirations like a normal
american girl
she just happens to be from india and
that's what's really amazing about this
story
is it's not an indian story and i i
would never want to put it into that
it's a it's a story of someone who just
happens to come across this like crazy
phenomenon
i gotta ask you sunita we got some news
that we did not expect this week
that coming to an end what
yeah really a shock she's
good right 2020 is just a great year
so this is just another one of those
uh yeah add it to the top of the pile
it's a bummer it's totally
a bummer and i feel a lot of things and
and processing it but it is like i can
take away
so many good things from that show
absolutely and it has
changed my life and and really changed
my career so i'm
i'm forever grateful and forever fond of
it
so it's not visit the earth not set
visit but the filming that you're doing
priyanka are you going to matrix 4 now
whoa
oh that's all i can say can you imagine
the gag order on that one
oh honey okay just personally what
excites you most about joining keanu in
the cast for
this blockbuster franchise i mean
exactly that
that it's it's it's iconic and
um to be able to get an opportunity to
even be a part of it
is is super exciting to me um as an
actor and also as a fan of the franchise
and to work with
lana is just she's such a force
um and her mind is so interesting to me
the world that she sees
in her mind is just fascinating so i'm
a student on that set and i learn and
imbibe everything that i can